how was
uh firefox born how's mozilla born
is there uh there's a long story there
too so netscape got
acquired by aol which as i say was a
reasonable happy ending for a lot of
people
because netscape otherwise was going to
go out of business because microsoft was
just
killing its market there was no way to
charge for a browser windows came with
ie
ia4 was pretty good and netscape 4
wasn't that good it took a while to get
better
um but the next game executive said
let's do
an open source escape pod you know and
like in star wars a new hope the
gunner won't shoot it because there's no
life forms on board right it's not a
threat
and so we did mozilla in 1998 and it
looked
like it was going to you know initially
just give the world of open source
browser
but it's really hard to get people to
work on this sort of hairball that had
been hacked up over
by that point four years uh it also
couldn't have the crypto module for
secure sockets so-called or now
transport layer security that was an
electronic munition we're not allowed to
release that
in the full 1024-bit
key strength and um yet
people one of whom i happened to meet
previously at sgi when i went
on a sales support engineering trip tim
hudson
in brisbane australia and um
eric a young did what became open ssl
it was called ssl eay after eric's
initials
and tim and eric took their open ssl
outside of the purview of the nsa and
the department of commerce
and they stuck it into mozilla's code
and that was perhaps the best hack that
was done
in the first few months after we open
sourced the browser
we had other problems the politics
inside netscape were driven by these
acquisitions so the one acquisition that
kind of
messed up netscape 4 also wanted to keep
doing a proprietary mail and groupware
program not jamie zawinski's mail
program that was netscape 2 and 3
and they held it back from open source
we didn't have a mail program it was
just a browser
we didn't know what aol will do to us
turns out they didn't interfere with us
for a long
time but netscape wasn't the best
steward of mozilla we were operating
mozilla as a pirate ship
without a legal entity so most of us
worked for netscape
under a separate organization and um
initially uh the first engineering
manager tom paquin
of netscape was the mozilla founding
manager but he he left pretty quickly
and he left me as the acting manager
which is more like method acting in my
case and um
and i i did that was my first management
stint but then
um someone who'd written the licenses
mitchell baker
she was a lawyer at netscape she was
involved in the open source
license decision making and the actual
writing and construction of those
licenses that was mitchell's job
netscape public license and the truly
open mozilla public license
and there were two because netscape
needed because of some uncovered code
needed some special rights but that went
away over time
mitchell was always interested in
mozilla and she came back from maternity
leave and she said i'll be the manager
if you want and jamie and i said sure
and then jamie quit he quit after a year
he said this didn't work i'm sorry
you know he acted like it was a total
failure because mozilla didn't
restart the browser market but there's
no way it could have right netscape was
still
shipping variants of netscape 4 which
was based on the old code
mozilla was trying to react to the code
to make green field for developers so it
was one of my big goals it wasn't a
technical goal so much as
again a social goal people wanted a more
standard
space browser they wanted them less of a
hair ball that had been hacked on
by ex-grad students starting four years
prior so
we said we're going to make a modular
code base we're going to use a variant
or an open source version of microsoft's
component object model
has reference counting and standardized
v tables virtual
calls and c plus plus and we're going to
use javascript we're going to have a
bridge between those two so you can
script those components just like
java components um we're going to make a
portable front end with a markup
language for the user user interface not
tables not html but
custom you know menus and drop-downs and
toolbars and
and that was called zuul xml user
interface language
and some real talent on the escape side
delivered that dave hyatt
who uh was instrumental in zul chris
waterson
um joe hewitt blake ross
and blake was an intern he was like a
high school-aged intern in that school
and at some point we were innovating
rapidly in the mozilla world
and netscape was still caught up in this
management mess from these acquisitions
and it wasn't delivering and
every year they were wondering if all
was going to come and start beheading
the executive because it didn't do
anything useful
and there was a thought you should take
the netscape browser engine and put it
in the windows aol
client which was the dial up client that
all the increasingly aging users of aol
were using
never happened it would have been too
big a change so it wasn't clear why it
all bought netscape but as i said they
left it alone but netscape didn't leave
mozilla alone
and so um in 2001
mitchell called me up and said i i'm no
longer employed and i'm like what
you quit no no this wasn't my choice and
there was a layoff
uh which maybe accidentally or on
purpose got rid of mitchell
but the funny thing was we had an open
source project we had a lot of the
engineers on staff
on our side and we had um
people we'd hired through the missoula
community were top-notch they'd risen
you know they came in high quality they
knew the code and they actually were
better than the average or median higher
of netscape
and so the funny thing was the
executive who thought they'd gotten rid
of mitchell in the layoff
on the next week's community call around
mozilla and what to do
there's mitchell and so this show you
can kind of transcend your
uh you know boundaries of corporate open
source if you get a project that has
enough loyalty even among the paid staff
because we had outside people
contributing
with people at red hat and a few other
places but the majority of the hackers
were employed by netscape
but a lot of them at that point had had
come from the community and others got
the community and wanted to work with it
it was really the weakest engineers at
netscape who didn't like mozilla and
didn't like the crucible of competing
with the the better
uh the programmers so if the project is
good enough it will rise the phoenix
will rise out of the
that's exactly right and so we had this
this mozilla code base that was getting
better in fact
i think at some point in 2002 when we
declared mozilla 1-0 we
i engineered a road map that
successively through similar sort of
six-week five-week releases
like we all do with browser releases
nowadays chrome does and firefox
um braved us three weeks we we we got to
a point where we said you know what
it doesn't suck this is like the 1-0
that you want
to release because if you hold it back
any longer to polish it you're denying
others the ability to use it so like pro
engineer the mechanical cad tool
embedded the code they embedded the
layout engine
um and mozilla 1 0 was like a netscape
communication suite we at that point
gotten male people to reintegrate mail
and news and we had
an editor for html and it felt like a
90s
sweet sweet ware and it felt kind of
bloated and the people
who were taking that mozilla open source
and then adding netscape
flavor to it we're not calling the shots
right and they were also under al's
thumb a little bit and that they said
well we should probably put the aol
instant messenger chiclet on the toolbar
we should put the icq
the other messaging system that they
acquired we should put the icq
you know button on the toolbar and
pretty soon netscape looked like a
bit of a nascar badged version of
mozilla
and that also made mozilla more popular
and and yet
um they they had you know contrived to
um fire or lay off the leader and
and and we carried on with an open
source structure where muslim
was still you know mitchell was calling
sort of management or
uh project level shots and i was calling
technical shots
and um we we had a popular suite but we
thought why not make it just a browser
because
it'll be simpler it'll do one job well
and even then we can strip it down by
having
extensions so dave hyatt and blake ross
the high school-aged intern did the
first version
which was called mozilla slash browser
it was very the small group of us ian
hicks and asa dotzler me and
uh joe hewitt and hyatt and
blake and and they and hyatt was really
the senior hacker he'd done all these
things like amazing
uh cross-platform menus through the user
interface
markup language um and he knew how to do
tab browsing he implemented it natively
on mac os at the time in camino um
originally called chimera he'd he'd
written multiple implementations which
was
i think programmers should do it's like
the v8 team did for those missing years
when the rest of the chrome team's like
where's v8
um in fact dave's wife rebecca told me a
story about when they were
at uiuc they were also universal
illinois uh grad students
um there was an assignment it was a
programming assignment supposed to do
the end of the semester
and dave's friend was this i'm gonna go
think and i'm gonna design and i'm going
to make this you know platonic perfect
form of the program and then i'm going
to write it at the end when it's due
and i just went there and started
hacking and you wrote one version you
wrote a second version a third version
end of the semester comes around the
friend's not doing too well
it wasn't perfect and it wasn't written
i'm not sure how that story ended but
for him but dave's version was
the fifth iteration was great and so he
done that with
everything you need in a tabbed browser
and this really showed well in
phoenix what we called phoenix and had
to rename two more times
um and you know uh blake went to
stanford he
became a stanford student and couldn't
work on it um dave hyatt
went to apple in 2001 he was one of the
founding safari team members um
interesting wow but he was still here
vlogging about
tabbed browsing i think apple at some
point said you could see sorry half time
browsing
yeah but it was because of hyatt yeah
high was quite a feather in their cap
don melton at uh who had been the
engineering manager at
for safari from the beginning uh had
been in netscape also
and so this is diaspora of talent and
and yet
hyatt was still kind of writing blog
posts about how to do tabs right
and at some point apple said don't don't
blog about that that's our proprietary
tab technology you know it's like no
it's not it was an opera and i've
refined it
um so we had to replace people and we
had
ben goodger uh new zealander we hired
nescafe and he
stepped in to be the firefox lead and we
also had this
weird circumstance where aol finally did
notice that netscape was kind of a
albatross they bought it for no
particular benefit and even then the aol
politics were also
heinous sort of east coast politics i
remember taking two trips there because
i was a principal engineer and so us
principal engineers got trotted out to
do
dog and pony shows in dulles virginia
and the uh
the aol upper management was very east
coast in flavor and
they were at that time merging with time
warner which would not go well
so one of these years we went out there
and we were all doing dog and pony shows
and there were
these characters that were sort of like
marketing guys one of the most wearing a
cravat and they were
one was named reggie and they were they
were they were
very um you
rather than non you or they were like
what's what's stillman's metropolitan
film uh
um urban
um they were hope they were um
funny and they were kind of useless and
kind of preppy
and then the next year we went back and
i said where's reggie and it's like oh
richie's not here anymore because time
warner
realized that the merger wasn't in their
interest either and then the sort of
knives came out
and this was these mergers really work
right this is very difficult you get
these giant companies and they think
there's going to be
synergy that was the 90s late 90s
watchword and there wasn't synergy with
aol by netscape and there wasn't synergy
with time warner
but did aol ever really work was it ever
really cool like
the same kind of fire and excitement
that firefox eventually created
was that ever there in aol the aol
was the right time to do a dial up
service that got distribution by
basically
leaflet bombing compact disks right on
the country
and they beat out compuserve and the
other ones
prodigy and then the web happened and so
you had
almost like this um isolated continent
like
some of the evolutionary biologists i
follow make fun of the
the funny large mammal you know
marsupial mammals of australia how
how silly they are and so aol is like
australia
and and you saw it over time because
they kept aging and they were using aol
to get online and
they couldn't really use a web browser
and it became sort of a
a valued cohort because they're still
have relatively high socioeconomic
status and they have grandchildren but
it's going away it's dying at some point
towards the end of the arts
that decade and then to the decade uh
2010 plus that firefox became
it's incredible i forget when chrome
came out but 2008 september 2008 but
firefox was the sexy cool
thing that represented a lot of the
cutting-edge technologies and all that
kind of stuff
it was amazing tim o'reilly and john
patel did the first web 2
conference which eventually became huge
and they split it but that was in 2004
it was right when firefox was out
craigslist was it was huge it was
killing classified revenue for
newspapers but
um there was just this ferment people
starting with media along there
somewhere gmail was already done and it
was an impressive web mail
there were others before like hotmail
but gmail is really impressive from
google
and google maps people started seeing
what could be done
they thought how can you drag the map
around and you know how does that work
and it was all javascript and images and
um so gmail was 2003 for so yeah
it actually started quite early it might
have been 2002 or three but by the time
we started dealing with google and
firefox to get the search deal which
was the main revenue source for mozilla
and still is um
2004 early sergey brin's uh one of his
trusted engineer guys fred schneider
made contact with me at mozilla and
we started talking and we realized
search and
browser need each other and this is
deeply true right this is still true
this is why a lot of the search engines
have their own browsers yeah so in case
people don't know the the main revenue
source for the browser
is the default search engine which is
kind of incredible to think about
that the that is a revenue source it's a
little bit sad
yeah it leads to this capture or kill
effect where you have the search engine
on its own browser and
other browsers may struggle to just get
this distribution we talked about
earlier
so where and you said uh you've
figured out that uh google is working on
its own browser at some point
2006 yeah 2006. so would you say firefox
versus
was internet explorer part of the war
here or was the firefox versus chrome
so firefox didn't quite cause microsoft
to reconvene i.e they did do ie7
and i remember being on a plane back
from the standards meeting javascript
standards meeting from
seattle from redmond and there was some
microsoft
guy in front of me it turns out my wife
knew him from her
past life before we married and he was
just this bearded big guy and he was
like
we should have just killed firefox in
the cradle all we needed to do was add
pop-up blocking in and tabs and we could
have made an internet
kill firefox and it's like shoulda
coulda woulda pal and i was right behind
him
hearing this um but they didn't they
were slow and they
ie7 wasn't that great and what really
got them started i think was
um chrome and you know i talked to larry
page in 2005. i think i said you know
we're talking about the firefox
relationship but he was also saying what
about webkit this was
apple's version of the old khtml
engine from from linux the kde side of
linux
that was used in the conqueror browser
also with case that
apple had forked and and in 2005 was
when apple's
principals including dave hyatt matches
takovic some of my friends who are still
there
said we must stop patch bombing this
poor kd
html project we should make a proper
mozilla-like organization webkit.org now
it wasn't a separate non-profit or
anything it was still apple it was apple
controlled but
they made their fork first class and
they made it be
something that they all worked in and
lived in and that was before chrome
and then chrome larry page said what
about webcam i said yeah it's nice i
have friends work on it
you might use that if you do your own
browser why don't you do your own browse
don't worry about firefox
you should do your own browser you can
have your own you know opinion of how it
should work and
and sure enough they did so by 2006 we
knew they'd been working on it some of
some of my friends who'd been at
netscape
did the original demo and the demo
wasn't what you thought it didn't have
the fast javascript yet that was still
off in denmark in the
farm um did i have tabs it had tabs
because all browsers had tabs at this
point
and it had this
software fault isolation i mentioned it
was through process isolation so
in theory each tab has its own operating
system process and so
what's going to take your tab down well
webkit has
bugs that can crash it but flash was
still big then all the restaurants sites
remember
and flash crashed a lot so the demo that
i heard about
my friends x netscape x as a lot of
people did inside google was
the sad tab they showed an early version
of chrome which is just this bare-bones
tab browser
they loaded a site with a known flash
volume and then suddenly
flash crashes and everyone expected the
whole browser to go down
but instead you got this little sad face
in the tab and you could reload it and
there it is again
so this was this was a an improvement it
was a real move for security
it was based on you know a company that
acquired called green border
they had some really big brains like
olfar erlingson i think was involved and
they had done some exotic
uh security stuff but they ended up
simplifying it to this process
isolation and um
it was good and firefox didn't have it
at the time so we were still struggling
with you know
the security bugs um
so we knew chrome was coming but it took
two more years to come out
and at the t we were still getting you
know the google search revenue we were
still um making google the default
engine
and firefox was still growing firefox
grew i think until 2011. that was when
it peaked
and as it started following it was
because of chrome chrome came out in
2008 and it was
a comic book that leaked accidentally
that showed some of the people who
worked on it larsbach was in there and
so on
it was kind of soft launched because
they didn't market it heavily they
didn't push distribution
but google had reason to worry about
distribution because microsoft
was you know doing a search engine bing
since 2007. in fact when they came out
with bing google was worried that
microsoft would just brute force switch
the default browser in everyone's
internet explorer or
even firefox on windows to bing from
google
and uh microsoft wasn't i think ready to
dare the anti-trust cops that way even
though
they'd gone to sleep and uh i don't
think bing was ready either
but just in case it happened sundar
pichai
who rose very well based on this work
was sort of
uh in charge of getting distribution
deals and he got google toolbar
and google desktop search distribution
and remember those pieces of software
those were like
desktop extensions toolbars
or operating system extensions for doing
desktop search searching your local
files kind of like
that's right mac os spotlight right
sadly data databases
and there were some features that we
still missed that didn't make it into
chrome but
sundar got oems to bundle those and then
he got enough of those deals that by
2007 or eight
google felt well if bing microsoft does
the worst and tries to force bing
we can reach in and reset it with that
point of presence
so that was you know good for sundara's
career and it was good for google but it
never came to pass that they had to
defend microsoft was still you know slow
and
by the time they saw chrome come out
then they did what would have been ie9
and then they said we're going to have a
fast javascript engine to
chakra chopper core uh they did okay
they were another process isolated
fast javascript browser tab browser so
it sounds like there's a deep
fundamental coupling of search engine
and browser that's
mixing this whole thing up and obviously
firefox doesn't have a
a search engine that's like i mean
you're
you're partnering with one with somebody
with a search engine yeah
with with yahoo or with uh yeah uh with
google or so on they tried yahoo that
was
unfortunate because i think um even
though marissa
mayer talked about it she never pulled
it off and never restored the search
uh team that had been laid off i believe
carol bartz was running yahoo when
carol said i've got to get rid of one of
three expensive things i'm going to get
rid of search
and um those researchers went to google
and microsoft and
there was no way to put yahoo search
back together so when firefox tried
switching
all their users who'd stuck with a
default from google to yahoo
like mid-december 2014 a bunch of users
said what
just happened to my firefox and others
didn't notice right away but over time
they did
and so over the next year the the
traffic just
went away for yahoo and and yet they
were obliged
i understand it i i don't have inside
knowledge but this is leaked out and
danny sullivan's written about it search
engine land i think the deal was like
fixed payments to mozilla so mozilla was
getting a bunch of money for traffic
that wasn't staying because users were
resetting their default and this shows
how defaults are important
but they have to be good enough that the
user doesn't override them
and you know a lot of the commercial
value in
popular apps is what are the default
settings what is the default search
but oftentimes there's something just
like you said i mean
if there's something compelling that's
also can beat out the default
like tab browsing and so on yes
you